カーテンなんですけどな告げて片方すぐ買ってなくて最近ようやく2月たのでここで
やっとカーテンでやっぽとかちょっと行けばネッツがねちょっと白目が背景にすること
ができましたグリーン博打でまぁ気持ち悪いしやめときますやっぱり仕様をベースにし
た方が綺麗なんで今度からこっち張って取ることが増えるかもしれません
こんにちははじめ社長のですちょっとツイッターであることを聞いてしまいました
何だろうなぁめんつゆめんつゆに2番愛して購入を混ぜるとおいしくなる的な感じなの
かなちょっとよくわかんないんですけどもそれでそういう感じだと思うけどそれを実際
にやってみようと思いますこれ買ったぞベンツいうこと路面追従性ピョンでそうめんを
買いましたら貞美さん子顔認証されるかな
みさこあみさんも3作顔認証されねーなーこのススメでしょうかこれ
すごい美沙子の美沙子のレシピが載ってますみさんもがんばってるなあそれを頑張れよ
ああ
あんな話だはじめ美沙子味は麺つゆとそのでとしている一人で行ってきますよした場合
せコーヒーでございます
微力ねーぞキャラメルけないあご自由にお取り下さいと言ってて気がするのはコーヒー
のはないからそのん
なんか魅力とか殺到の鍵がわからないんですよ
伊賀にがにが一プコーヒーが苦手なんですけどもうめんつゆにコーヒーを入れて装備を
食べるかめちゃくちゃおいしくなるって話を聞いたんでちょっと今回ソ超えってみ空母
パーセぺんっぺちぱ
やるよじゃあまたちょっとそうめんをつくってみまーす湯の中に麺を空から言って箸で
軽くかき混ぜてください
なるほどの東京応化
ああああああ
まあを目指しに面談できたん
ブーブー s 4あああーーぬぅあああああぬーっ
手袋さっきだろセブンっ
ああああああ
生きろよ無理だよ無理だよこれ火傷するよ火傷しそうな客観の場所だけ抑えてとるぞ
ああ待って今日の夜ご飯何だけど ok ok ok ok
バーン
よし ok 台になりましたもうほぼ全部です酒編なるなんでこんなんそーめん大変な
のソアーチャー愛的でなんとかそうめんはできました
めんつゆ普通にメンツを懸けたバージョンとウォッチン雛瀬に面体をかけたバージョン
とアイスコーヒーを入れたバージョンでちょっと試したいと思いますまあとりあえず
まず普通のバージョンをちょっと食べてみよう
ノーマルバージョンいただきます
ええええええ
マイン別に実験とかいいからそのまま全部食べたいねだとこれうまいなぁ国内でも
これ薄めなくていいのかな
だからやっぱ水入れなきゃじゃあ困ってそうね行っちゃいさん
水着だけじゃんあの一帯30年からまあ水に上げ下げ the
メンチ市水さんだから数にこれなら美味しいはずと食べてみますいただきます
運命最高に美味しいですこれって事は取って混ぜるかって言うとその水がファン面子
13台中のバリューなんですけどその水をアイスコーヒーにすれば美味しくなるんじゃ
ないかなという話なのではないでしょうか
そそれでて実はまずは麺2日アイスコーヒー3でやってみます
こんな感じだとはこれ使いで味から切る
これ自体に味比べしてみましょうこれでこっちの多い叱ったらもうやばいねなんか
そうめんの常識を覆すような結果になるよってこれコーヒー嫌いなんだよね見た目的に
はあんまり下部まで黒いなぁ
苦労いなぁ女度的にあまり変化ないと思うんですけどもこっちがアイスコーヒー混ぜた
ばですよこっちがノーマルバージョンです
注ぎ
ただきますまずノーマル
うん
アイスコーヒーば塗っています
怖いなぁ
いやこれ吠えまってまっおかしくね美味しくはないの
面子の阿南苦味が足されて苦くなりましたみたいな
これがおどらんなージってやつかねや普通の方があるけど美味しかったです
皆さんもぜひやってみてくださいたぶん普通の方が美味しいと思います
じゃ